&gt;&gt; The first step we need to take, and this is actually a little bit tricky, is
to recognize that we have a term of 24x squared on both sides of the equation.
That means, if we subtracted from both sides, we'll just get rid of it entirely.
That's definitely going to make our lives simpler. Now, I'm going to move all of
my x terms, so that they're on the left side of the equation. And all of my
constant terms, so that they're on the right. All that's left to do is divide
both sides by 60. Recognizing that 38 and 60 are both divisible by 2, we can
cancel out that common factor, and get a final answer of x equals 19 over 30.
Awesome. I know that was a really, pretty intricate and complicated equation to
solve. But look at where we came from. We started off with all of these messy
fractions, and we ended up with, well, an answer that is a fraction, but it's an
answer nonetheless. I'd like you to plug this answer into the places of x in the
original equation, to make sure that it actually works. Please remember to check
the left hand side on its own, and the right hand side on its own, and then
compare the two.